did you ever get to meet Michael Jackson
no I didn't man I wish I did though you
know I was what [__] 10 when he died
damn that would have been the time to
meet him yeah yeah yeah yeah man sad
times though you know King of Pop yeah
King of Pop I was at a I was on stage
one time and he pulled up in the alley
outside of the window in uh wait wait
wait wa you you have seen Michael
Jackson yeah I saw him like you've seen
him I visually saw him outside of a
second story window he was going into
the uh costume shop it was at night and
it was closed but they opened it up for
him and and he pulled up and I saw him
kind of get out and he got out all
[__] like he just looked like he was
just like he barely
[__] like he just got out you know
like he he just kind of like was out you
know he didn't have to really do a lot
yeah it seemed like he just wasn't there
wasn't a lot to him you know he was very
like he's a fragile person he's very
fragile yeah yeah he looked fragile man
uh how tall was Michael Jackson
that's a good
question that is a good question I have
no clue how tall Michael Jackson I never
thought about how like uh 5 foot n 5'9
that's that's kind of small bro yeah
yeah he's a smaller guy damn yeah cuz he
started looking Asian at the end huh he
switched up he made a big switch up he
went through all he went every he didn't
[__] miss a gender he didn't miss a
ethnicity he Mexican
all man he hit them all for real then he
went past white like the white he went
was like pass what the [__] white is
like we're like oh he's the one that did
slavery bro we were all pointing at him
what the fu we like that [__]
did it bro we were pointing at him dude
he looked like Jackie O at the end bro
pull up Jackie O man dang cuz he went
all away man dang bro you know his dad
was beating the [__] out of them though
oh he was beating the [__] out of that's
probably dad look like that now a damn
ball sack but a lot of black guys can
sing anyway it's like a why would you
even beat your kid into singing yeah
yeah but he was talented I think he just
wanted them to be perfect though you
know yeah yeah damn
bro some sometimes you get Excellence
out of that though yeah yeah yeah I
wonder if people you could beat somebody
into Excellence maybe that's an example
of it huh that's an example but you know
they they lose their mind after it it
all so it's it's it's it's a bad Trail
just just downhill Trail man that's sad
I'm friends with his daughter she's
awesome Janet Janet Jackson no Paris
Jackson who the [__] is that oh Michael
Jackson's daughter daughter yeah are you
really yeah she's a sweetheart wow um
where's blanket can we where is blanket
let's talk about blaby BL blanket
disappeared right oh I don't know I
think he changed his name and everything
he's not really yeah I think yeah I
don't think Blanket Jackson is [__]
throw rug or something he look different
blanket is like a cuz a lot of brothers
used to have crazy names back in the day
blanket whisker yeah you meet his
brother nam whis I think he changed his
name didn't he damn he kind of had that
Native American
look wow did did Michael Jackson used
his own nut to make his kids oo couldn't
have you mean into a woman he look
Indian yeah there's no way that ain't no
black Jean in that he look like full
moon walk yeah yeah yeah that's
yeah no black Jean in that blood right
there I think know yeah but that's a
good question right I think even the
Paris Jackson how does she look she's
completely white right she has more of a
white look she has a little bit I think
she gets you can see a little bit of um
like there you go ain't no ain't no
black in that I don't know she got a
little bit Urban in the eyes I think in
the eyes I think so they're [__] blue
yeah but they [__] want to be black
how how how do they want to be black you
can see look in them bch zoom in Zach
dang come on man let's see we
guessing yeah yeah n that's I don't see
any black there man other than the
pupils yeah that's a little that's about
it yeah no he didn't make that with his
nut he didn't make that with his nut man
I'm telling you I don't know that's
funny yeah cuz I guess if you are not
cuz I don't know if he was attracted to
I guess he was attracted to women huh
yeah yeah yeah but who knows you know
yeah it's Michael Jackson
yeah dude
yeah